حلف شمال الاطلسي على بعد ايام من اكبر
مناورات عسكريه جويه في تاريخه عشره ايام
ستشهد مناورات الدفاع الجوي يردفندر 23
بقياده المانيه مناوره قد تربك حركه النقل
الجوي المدني لضخامتها في المانيا
تدريبات تشارك فيها حوالي 220 طائره
عسكريه من 25 دوله من اعضاء الناتو اضافه
الى اليابان والسويد الراغبه بالانضمام
للحلف عشره الاف جندي بينهم الفا جندي
امريكي هو عديد القوات المشاركه في اكبر
مناورات مرتبطه بنشر القوات الجويه في
اوروبا
المناورات ستشمل تدريبات عملياتيه وعلى
المستوى التكتيكي خصوصا في المانيا وتشيكو
استونيا ولاتفيا مناورات وان كانت دفاعيه
تحت بطبيعتها كما يقول مسؤولون غربيون الا
ان الهدف منها ايصال رسائل واضحه ومباشره
لدول بينها روسيا اضواء
[موسيقى]
رسائل الميتو لا تنتهي لكن ذات المناورات
اطلقت عام 2018 كجزء من الرد على ضم شبه
جزيره القرم من اوكرانيا عام 2014 تاتي
اليوم وسط اتون حرب روسيه طاحنه في
اوكرانيا مشهد استراتيجي يقول مدير الحرس
الجوي الوطني الامريكي انه تغير كثيرا حول
العالم وخصوصا في اوروبا ما وضع مهام
النيتو عند منعطف على حد وصفه
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات